pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la visite à washington n'était officiel
mais chaleureuse l'alt à new york devait
être pour employer un autre courant
formidable la tique telle parade que new
york réservé au général de gaulle en
effet dépassé tous les précédents connus
pour la visite d'un chef d'état étranger
cet honneur peut-on dire se mesure à
l'ampleur de la chute de confettis
serpentins pages de botha déchiré que la
population envoie des fenêtres sur le
héros du jour on en ramasse à 400 kg sur
le passage de coup de chauffe 700 sur
celui de 2 go
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
24 heures plus tard le même spectacle le
même déploiement populaire serait édité
à san francisco c'est dans un nuage de
confettis et serpentins
le président de la république a fait son
entrée triomphale dans la capitale de
l'ouest américain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette ville aux 14 colline le président
a pu en contempler les aspects en
faisant le tour de la baie célèbre
aborde un garde-côte avant de s'envoler
pour la nouvelle orléans où devait
s'achever
son périple nord américain
c'est à la nuit dans une ville dans les
feux illuminés des milliers de drapeaux
tricolores que le général de gaulle a
parcouru la ville la plus française des
états unis quatre cent trente six ans
ont passé depuis que les envoyés de
françois 1er reconnurent ces terres qui
devait porter le nom de louisiane et qui
à travers les temps ont conservé dans la
langue les moeurs et l'esprit une
authentique tradition française comme à
new york comme à san francisco les
acclamations n'ont pas manqué le
président de gaulle a fait au cours de
son voyage la conquête des états unis
[Musique]
la série des séismes continue la ville
de lar en iran a été transformée en
champ de ruines par deux secousses d'une
extrême violence
le drame a fait plus de 500 morts et le
nombre des blessés est important le
reste de la population qui s'élevait à
quelque 17000 personnes demeurent sans
abri et l'arrivée des secours toile et
tentes couvertures ou vivre provoque
parfois des controverses qui vont
jusqu'à la violence
naturellement les épidémies sont à
craindre et les services médicaux qui
évacue les grands blessés par avion
s'efforcent de maîtriser le danger au
milieu d'une population qui vit toujours
dans la crainte d'un nouveau tremblement
de terre une semaine de violences à
semer le deuil dans de nombreuses
familles coréennes
on compte officiellement plus de 100
morts mais les évaluations officieuses
parle d'un chiffre plus élevé c'est dans
ce tumulte sanglant que s'est terminé le
régime de sigma murray avec la fin
tragique de son ami et collaborateur le
vice président lee qui pompent dont la
maison n'est plus qu'un amas de ruines
fumantes la démission de thin man ray
les cède en effet le pouvoir au
vice-président l'équipe hong convoite
ici entourée de toute sa famille au jour
de son élection
accablé par les événements l'équipe hong
kong prétendez l'homme de paille de
sigma break s'est donné la mort avec
tous les siens dans un suicide collectif
[Musique]
les manifestations qui s'étaient succédé
sans interruption chaque jour de la
semaine devant le palais présidentiel se
sont apaisées qu'avec ce suicide
spectaculaires et l'élévation à la
présidence du ministre des affaires
étrangères ou chung qui a promis des
réformes et de nouvelles élections
du même coup les manifestations
violentes ont tourné en acclamations
[Musique]
le muguet du 1er mai est une coutume à
laquelle les français restent fidèles
c'est ainsi que sur l'initiative du
commissariat général au tourisme
les hôtesses de france sont allés à
l'aéroport d'orly remettre le brin de
muguet traditionnels aux touristes venus
de tous les coins du monde
[Musique]
une bonne idée et un joli geste
un village des bords de loire la ferme
paternelle
c'est là que les six enfants de monsieur
boumier tous religieux ou missionnaires
se sont retrouvés après quarante années
de séparation
[Musique]
un événement pour saint gemmes dans
toute la population on avait d'ailleurs
mobilisé leur fait on a tenu à
accompagner jusqu'à la petite église
les deux soeurs et les quatre frères
enfin réunis au pays natal
c'est dans cette église que devait avoir
lieu en présence de l'évêque d'angers
la première messe à laquelle en 40 ans
les six frères et soeurs auront pu
assister en simple la dernière peut être
puisque demain chacun de repartir à pour
sa mission
[Musique]
à lui seul paris dévore 12 millions de
lettres par jour devant cette masse de
courrier toujours plus imposante
le facteur a pu rester semblable annuel
mais le sac du facteur n'est que le
terme d'un circuit qui commence à la
boîte aux lettres et dans ce circuit
quelque chose a radicalement changé le
tri à la main qui procède par étapes et
oblige à lire plusieurs fois la même
adresse a reçu sa condamnation au centre
principal de paris il a été remplacé par
une machine réalisé par hotchkiss grant
une seule intervention désormais chaque
département est déterminé par deux
lettres et taylor tous les mécanismes
dans toulouse bras articulé capitte
engrenage vont agir de telle sorte que
chaque enveloppe gagne son casier
particulier
au rythme de 25 milles à l'heure les
lettres vont tâcher allait occuper l'un
des 300 réceptacle correspondant chacun
à une destination
ne restera plus qu'à mettre en liasses
le contenu de chaque réceptacle pour le
train ou l'avion
[Musique]
demain on verra mieux encore la machine
à trier électronique expérimenté par le
centre national des flips de
télécommunications l'adresse est mat
l'autre habitant code une fois pour
toutes sur le dos même de l'angle
[Applaudissements]
plus besoin de donner d'ordres
d'acheminement à la machine devenue
peut-on dire font sens elle décidera
elle-même de l'opération de tri sur
simple lecture du code par un oeil
électronique
et le jour viendra enfin où la machine
capable également de contrôler au
brassage l'affranchissement des lettres
lira directement l'adresse que nous
aurons nous même traduite en code alors
que plus récents et opérera son tri sans
intervention d'aucune sorte
toujours plus vite cette règle d'or de
notre siècle a mise à l'heure des robots
les services des postes créés par louis
ix hante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'image de raymond kopa numéro 9 les
joueurs du stade de reims ont prouvé
devant l'équipe de nîmes qu'ils sont
bien les meilleurs footballeurs français
premier but pour reims oeuvre de la
nouvelle vague rémois c'est-à-dire de
l'amateur biernat un joueur percutant
qui fera peut-être oublier fontaine dans
quelques années
tout cela ne va pas cependant sans
quelques jolis réaction des nîmois ici
ce qui bat numéro 9 qui de son côté
symbolise les qualités de son équipe
n'est me donne le frisson aux rémois
pour le moment
[Applaudissements]
à ce petit intermède n'est mois succède
en deuxième mi temps le festival des
attaquants drass voyait plutôt qu'aux
pas vincent qui lance muller numéro 8
talonnade de müller sur vincent les
spectateurs en sont médusés
et puis quand madonna piantoni dans le
trou qui ne manque pas une si belle
occasion
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi parachève la victoire de son
équipe par un extraordinaire numéro
personnel regardez bien un joueur dans
le vent deux joueurs puis toute la
défense le gardien de but y compris pas
de chance la balle heurte le poteau mais
bien anthony et la 3 0 1 c'est
pratiquement champion
[Musique]